right in the case of Senator Al Franken
here is what we have he admitted to some
of it and we have irrefutable
photographic evidence let me explain
actress/model radio host LeAnn tweeting
has been on this program many times came
forward today with stunning allegations
against Democratic senator Al Franken
that he is now admitting to and he is
now apologizing for now according to
tweed enduring a 2006 USO tour in
Afghanistan then citizen Al Franken had
written a skit where he kissed Sweden
and Franken demanded that they quote
rehearse it backstage after tweetIn
refused she described what allegedly
happens next at a press conference
earlier today what's this he just put
his hand on the back of my head and he
mashed his face again so it mean it
happened so fast and he just mashed his
his lips against my face and he stuck
his tongue in my mouth so fast and all I
can remember is that his lips were
really wet and it was slimy in my mind I
called him fish lips the rest of the
trip because that's just what it
reminded me of I don't know why and he
stuck his tongue down my my mouth and I
remember I pushed him off with my hands
and I just remember I almost punched him
so cuz every time I seen him now like my
hands clenched into fists and I'm sure
that's probably why and I said if you
ever do that to me again I'm not gonna
be so nice about it the second time I
was violated I just felt like you know
he betrayed my trust and obviously that
it's not what I wanted and it gets worse
from there look at this
photo while leaving from Afghanistan
tweeting fell asleep and Franken
proceeded as you can see there to grope
her tweet and says that she didn't even
know what happened until after she got
home and looked at pictures of this trip
now tweeting further detailed the
incident at a news conference earlier
today let's take a look the photo of all
doing his you know this on my breast
like looking at the camera just kind of
smirking and smiling like hey look at me
he just thought he could get away with
it and
it was okay and that it was funny
nothing like that is ever funny I mean
is it funny if he does that to your
sister or your daughter or your wife in
context of already assaulting me
backstage and and all the little petty
things he was doing to belittle me and
and and how he treated me and sort of
you know in succession and then it ended
with that look I was afraid to speak out
11 years ago I wanted to say something
and there were people around me and said
oh my god you will get annihilated and
you will never work in this town again
and I was afraid of that and this
afternoon Lee ant Whedon did an
interview and it got very emotional take
a look it's not a feel-good thing I
still feel sort of embarrassed about it
you know you always and I want to be
cliche but you know you talk about
trying to leave the world a better place
for your kids you know sorry nothing to
be sorry about
huh I didn't think I was going to do
that but you know you do you you want to
leave you know you try to set examples
for your children right you want to
leave the world a better place now I
also interviewed Lee Ann tweed and on my
radio show earlier today listening what
do you think should happen I know they
were trying to pressure you in the press
conference there's something like that
warrant is he belong in the Senate you
know I'm not calling for him to sit down
that's not why I came out with this I
just want other people if you know there
might be other girls that he did this to
and obviously you have one on the phone
right now that's talking with me and
there might be other Al Franken did
issue a statement apologizing for the
photo but claims to not remember the
backstage kissing incident it reads in
part quote I don't know what was in my
head when I took that picture and it
doesn't matter
there's no excuse I look at it now I
feel disgusted with myself it isn't
funny it's completely inappropriate
now Franken is also agreeing to a senate
ethics investigation which Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell first
called for and then Democrats like Chuck
Schumer Claire McCaskill quickly
supported because they had no choice and
ethics investigation my mind takes too
long and by the way is it a delay tactic
it's also funny how some Republicans are
giving franken well are they giving him
a pass by only calling for an
investigation LeeAnn tweetIn is also
weighing in and saying it should go even
further than that by having an outside
investigation into the Senators
inexcusable actions now what Franken has
admitted to which we have photographic
evidence right there and what he's
accused of doing is pretty downright
creepy but sadly it's just the tip of
the iceberg when it comes to Al Franken
things you probably won't hear on any
other show for example on the Senate
floor in 2010 senator Franken described
his USO trips and called LeAnn tweed and
beautiful watch this I was kind of a
co-host with a beautiful woman named
Leanne tweetIn and we do comedy routines
and we'd introduce music and it is the
hatred cheerleader now Franken is also
being accused of harassing a second
woman Melanie Morgan a radio TV
personality also the co-founder of the
website media equalizer
Morgan is alleging that back in 2000
while appearing with Franken on Bill
Maher show on ABC politically incorrect
the two had a heated debate on camera
which then continued backstage according
to Melanie Morgan Franken then got her
phone number from one of the show's
producers and called her three separate
times
she said harassing her until Morgan
threatened to call the police now I
interviewed Melanie Morgan about these
accusations of harassment on my radio
show earlier today let's listen tit
Melanie what did what do people to think
when we don't have a picture like in the
case of LeAnn how do you had old people
sort through and get to the truth that
is a great question and it's one and as
a journalist of over 30 years experience
I wrestle with every single day you know
you have to take these instances and
these testimonials by different women
and it's usually women although in
Hollywood as we've learned sometimes
it's men and you have to look at the
whole context in which these allegations
are made
you know I wanted to give judge Roy
Moore the benefit of the doubt because
it was 40 years ago that he was accused
of doing some inappropriate things I
think that the people of Alabama are
definitely going to make a judgement on
what they think is true and what is not
true I can only speak us to the truth
that I experienced which was a very
aggressive and almost obsessive behavior
that senator Al Franken displayed
towards me when he was a writer and a
performer on politically incorrect with
Bill Maher now like in the case of
Senate candidate Roy Moore these are all
very serious allegations that need to be
fully investigated in this case by the
Senate Ethics Committee and to be fair
we did reach out to Senator Franken we
did invite him on the show to tell his
side of the story he just heard part of
my radio interviews with Lee Ann tweed
inand Melanie Morgan now we also invited
those that had accused worried more on
this program we've also reached out at
the Hillary Clinton Nancy Pelosi so far
they didn't get back to us no comment
now when it comes to senator Al Franken
here's what you probably haven't heard
he has a long history of making all
kinds of vicious vile completely out of
line comments he's also a massive
hypocrite when it comes to sexual
harassment for example in 1995 he was
working on Saturday Night Live on a
quote skit where he suggested drugging
and raping Lesley Stahl from 60 minutes
he said at the time quote I give the
pills to Lesley Stahl then when Leslie's
passed out I take her to the closet and
rape her and that's why you'd never see
Lesley until February or when she passes
out I put her in various positions and
take pictures of her what kind of person
is making jokes about drugging and
raping women then in 2000 Al Franken
wrote a quote so-called satirical
article for Playboy magazine with the
headline porn Arama
most of it is too vulgar to read on TV
but in part one part in particular
Franken wrote I'm talking about
the internet which is a terrific
learning tool for example a couple years
ago when he was 12 my son used the
internet for a sixth grade report on
bestiality and in the article Franken
goes on to fantasize about a machine
that would perform oral sex on him and
it gets worse into
and eight when Franken was running for
Senate he was forced to apologize for
what he wrote in Playboy and his crude
and appalling comments about Lesley
Stahl but in his new book Franken
actually said that he faith those
apologies in order to win votes his own
words he writes to say I was sorry for
writing a joke was to sell out my career
to sell out who I had been my entire
life and I wasn't sorry that I had
written porn or Amma or pitch that
stupid Lesley Stahl joke at 2:00 in the
morning I was just doing my job
so I guess based on his own words from
this point forward we can only assume
that any apology from Senator grope it
will only be lies in order to win votes
in the future
examples of frankenz despicable behavior
don't end there during a Friars Club
roast of Rob Reiner Franken made jokes
about infant rape how sick do you have
to be to make jokes about raping babies
then you have senator Franken explaining
how he considered calling Republicans
quote gay when they didn't attend a
hearing on an LGBT bill watch this we
had a bill called the end of the you
know end discrimination in employment
Employment non-discrimination Act so no
Republicans showed up for the hearing
which I had never seen before I've been
there for four or five months and this
is the first hearing I'd been in where a
whole party just didn't show up so I'm
sort of last in line and I think of
saying like I think it's a shame that
none of the gay members of the committee
show so that's what the devil on one
side well that's the devil was saying
goblet joke
don't kill to top it all off there's
this photo from 2000 of Al Franken
actually again groping joy behar and a
red carpet maybe they thought it was
funny but it makes a lot of people
uncomfortable especially in light of the
photo we saw with LeAnn tweed in' looks
repulsive he doesn't even try to hide it
in two cases he's literally posing for
the camera it makes you wonder are there
other photos Franken doing the same
thing just to recap quickly Franken is
accused of groping
kissing a woman accused of harassing
another he's made comments about
drugging and raping and women and is
also homophobic clearly doesn't end
there
senator Al Franken is also a hypocrite
when it comes to women speaking out
about sexual abuse just take a look at
some of his tweets well we must address
sexual harassment reforming arbitration
laws will ensure survivors can seek
justice in court thanks to courageous
people who have shared hashtag me to
stories including senator Heitkamp and
senator Hirono and Senator Claire
McCaskill and Senator Warren now Franken
also praised the women who exposed
Harvey Weinstein it's kind of
hypocritical think about this for a
second just one second time that picture
of Lee Ann tweed just for one second you
see that got released today imagine it
was showing a Republican imagine the
president Trump was in that picture how
would the media act on that issue
tonight they would be apoplectic it
would be the biggest news story of the
year
they'd be breathlessly condemning the
incident demanding that person resigned
immediately not just calling for an
ethics committee hearing tonight senator
Al Franken well he should be ashamed as
he said he is because it is repulsive
Lee aunt Whedon is asleep we have to ask
again given this information everything
we now know now considering everyone's
raising questions who's fit for this
office and who's fit for that office is
Senator Franklin fit for office now
senator Franken clearly is a pretty sick
twisted individual with a warped sense
of humor in his own mind that really
isn't funny but his actions do need to
be evaluated at the end of the day will
be the people in his home state that
decide and what's really shocking what's
really outrageous is that senator
Franken is not alone when it comes to
accusations of sexual misconduct against
members of Congress according to a new
office compliance numbers that were
released today since 1997 15 million of
your taxpayer dollars have been used to
settle allegations of sexual misconduct
discrimination in other cases against
members of Congress why don't they pay
themselves in other words you're
subsidizing their behavior and for years
it's been kept secret even though there
have been 264 cases settled now there
are also reports about what's being
called the Capitol Hill creep list which
helps warn people about which members of
Congress
congressional employees to avoid and
finally tonight a quick update on the
Clintons day of reckoning for years we
have been shedding a light on the
allegations of sexual misconduct by Bill
Clinton and how Hillary smeared all of
those accusers and all of their friends
did they smeared slandered besmirched we
went into it in great detail last night
in our opening monologue we broke it
down in all its detail we encourage you
if you didn't see it go back you may
want to see it
so now after nearly 30 years of covering
for Bill Clinton now the media is
finally realizing oh wait a second Bill
Clinton we kind of enabled him he is a
sexual predator take a look at some of
these headlines one from Vox and says
Bill Clinton should have resigned what
he did to Monica Lewinsky was wrong and
should have paid the price
the New York Times even says what about
Bill Clinton what about Bill sexual
misconduct debate revised questions
about Clinton we have to ask what took
everyone in the liberal mainstream media
so long isn't because that they're
Democrats and they like their policies
it's time they all come forward they
enabled that abuse of predatory behavior
for decades and by the way as a result
many women suffered we have a lot more
to come